[Musique]
bon sang comment nous sommes à québec
dans une rencontre du gappi groupe dead
aux personnes impulsives ce après quoi
comme déclic pour les deux thérapeutes
lens à peine la conversation que déjà
les quatre hommes présents la séance ont
envie de se confier heureux le pas tout
ce que je vois ils ont tous un passé
marqué par la violence folle ex échoué
moucaye rays
certains sont venus volontairement
cherché de l'aide - la première est
celle de vieira ce que je laissais mon
ex femme
d'autres sont obligés de suivre la
thérapie teinte la claque port des
suites après ben tu regrettes sur
demande pardon tu jettes l'autize nos
excuses - j'excuse mon excuse moi je
recommencerai plus jamais peut-être pas
plus tard qu'avant si richard reconnaît
avoir levé la main sur son ex
dany n'a jamais frappé sa femme
ce n'est même jamais été franchie j'ai
jamais levé la main sur sur mon ex femme
ou sur une conjointe mais il admet
aujourd'hui avoir été très violent
envers elle des menaces je vois partir
soit travaux sur ce temps ça marche à
pas ma manière bien qu'ils ont données
de l'acss ahdab en charge une porte
parce que les anneaux coup de poing d'un
métal troupes pour que ça soit plus
craints et si plus de c est le plus
parce que tu veux que je peux avoir ce
que je vous donne semble dans le couple
c'est dany qui contrôlent l argent
puisse penser de coin d'un dense mais
c'était pour mieux la faire plutôt que
de transférer l'argent sur bg retard des
gens retardé le transfert d'argent pour
la faire chier
effectivement ça marchait parce que moi
j'étais la personne qui a un intérêt de
gros de l'argent à la maison donc tout
m'était du loto faire sur 60 points 3
mois 0 7 heures demain que ça marche
pour daniela violence c'était aussi le
mépris jusque dans les rapports sexuels
ça fait quelques jours je prends la
maison oui j'ai des besoins et pourrait
vraiment pas dans ce moule l'eau puis
l'a pas été
c'était certain c'est insiste jusqu'à
trenca finissent par dire oui c'était
centre sur monster ça se peut comme il
n'a jamais frappé sa conjointe dany ne
s'était jamais perçu comme un homme
violent
il se voyait au contraire comme un homme
droit toujours prêt à combattre les
injustices
je voulais tout le temps défendre la
veuve et l'orphelin
si vous vous avez vu avec votre ex en
public vous auriez pas tolérer ça je
m'en serais crise est un jeu me sera
créé ce nouveau look
parce que ce que j ai fait vivre ccpo
ccpo connecte par d'autres plusieurs
mois après son divorce
dany prend conscience que son
comportement est inacceptable
je t'avais qu'à nouvelle conjointe avait
voulu aller faire une petite commission
a vite fait dans l'auto à le prime et
espadrilles et domi moi je peux leur
médecin à la ruhr chèques alors je suis
rentré ici pinzi badri palau écrasé les
renforts avec ses talons quand kerjean
trade en maison dit tu pourras faire
attention à mes espadrilles tabarnak
puis alain comme figé un mort car d âme
disait moi non j'ai pas besoin d'autres
soldats ma vie elle méritait pas ça du
tout avec des potes vivent seuls 6,8 à
cet épisode look dernier accepte
finalement d'écouter ses proches d'aller
chercher de l'aide aux gappi s'en sont
ici ou ce que je serais je le cpo
potiche en prison je sais pas faire deux
fois que le sujet des répits kg chemin
dur à contrôler et verbaliser de gens
partaient ça fait maintenant plusieurs
années que dany vient on rencontre les
hommes les thérapeutes du gappi sont
devenus au fil des ans des amis des
confidents qu'ils aident à gérer son
impulsivité
c'est ce que tu peux pas demander à
quelqu'un de céder si vous possédez ça
c'est sûr et certain nous a même tire
que je ne peux pas te dire à un
alcoolique d'art et de boire s'il veut
parler de bons chiens de moins puis elle
je me suis dit babin excellent si juste
mon passage avec vous aujourd'hui peut
aider une personne à céder de lui-même
ben c'est pour ça qu'elles font